here's a sentence I thought I would
never say but I spent the afternoon with
Prince Harry and Megan Ellen DeGeneres's
summer was 100 times more regal than
mine and yours I just want to say it was
an honor for them to meet me and no but
like literally it was regal AF also we
flew to London did some sightseeing or
as they call it
we took the whirlybird to do some lucky
me loose Ellen and her wife Portia de
Rossi visited Prince Harry Megan Markel
and a little baby Archie in London and
she opened up about her experience with
the Royals on Monday's episode of The
Ellen DeGeneres Show seriously they are
so amazing they're the cutest couple and
so down-to-earth and just a I just hate
it I see them get attacked and it's not
fair they're just two of the most
down-to-earth compassionate people
they're doing so much good for the world
oh you thought she was done not even
close
Ellen continued to sing the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex is praises and even
teased a potential charitable collab
between herself and the royal couple
portion I talked to them about all the
conservation they're doing for wildlife
and they're doing all this work in
Botswana for elephants and I love that
and they like what I'm doing and for the
gorillas in Rwanda so we're gonna all do
something together okay now here's where
it gets real freaking cute not only did
Ellen get to talk to Harry and Megan
about their mutual passions but she also
got to meet their four-month old son
Archie I mean I can't tell you how sweet
they are but the most important thing is
I got to hold little Archie the baby
I fed Archie I held Archie not like that
I knew how to hold it right
like that
he weighs 15 pounds which is the
exchange rate I believe is $17 here
and while Ellen says she didn't snap a
selfie with the itty-bitty she did share
a funny drawing of the newborn he looks
like Harry he's uh he has a body but I
just did the face for y'all
cute right but this isn't the first time
that Ellen has spoken out in defense of
Megan and Harry in August she tweeted
about meeting with the Royals and shut
down the haters who criticized them for
their private jet vacations she wrote
quote they were the most down-to-earth
compassionate people she added imagine
being attacked for everything you do
when all you're trying to do is make the
world's better um can someone just make
me the president of Ellen DeGeneres's
fan club already I freakin love that
lady of course we'll be right here to
keep you up to date on all things Ellen
and all things Royals so make sure to
subscribe to all things et until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]